à l'étal sa race
[Musique]
on rappelle le principe on va pouvoir
gagner un billet pour la laponie en
grimpant cette échelle et en allant
chercher le billet qui est en haut boris
est ce que tu peux nous faire une petite
démonstration on vous montrer que c'est
hyper simple franchement tu le fais
souvent bien c'est la première fois que
tu le veuilles ou non ça fait plusieurs
années j'avais hâte à fait d'accord mais
on va dire que c'est la première fois
que je fais on va la refaire
bon il s'apprend vois tu le fais oui
c'est le bonheur vas-y mon bord y
regarder c'est très simple il va aller
chercher le billet vous connaissez voilà
il ya une échelle non
voilà voilà voilà pour un combo brabo
bobo est bon voilà boris excellent mais
c'est pour vous montrer que c'est assez
simple voilà normalement il n'y a pas de
souci allez
voilà à les remercier monte à l'endroit
on écrit pour monter comme une échelle
voilà sinon moi je vais arriver là je
vais le prendre comme ça
car sans ça madame la machinerie ça va
ma chérie ouais bah ouais ça va d'un
film là je suis en mode à la phonie mais
j'aime bien aussi gagner ce temps paul
maurice voilà merci à l'est il s'est
fait aussi
ah ça partait bien allez merci jean mi
c'est horrible à celui qui a fait mieux
avec machine qui était pas si mal mineur
dans sa cachette
citoyen sa cinquième femme en excuse moi
ne confondez pas perdu c'est bien qui
finit bien
[Applaudissements]
au portugal
après
[Musique]